[Music]
this place is insane
[Music]
city is the front line for a people's
mind and a couple of grenades I'm not
gonna lie this is sort of a rough bus
stop with a fair amount of drunks
walking around so I don't feel like
putting my camera up into the mix and
I'm off to marry opal and Metis opal is
this city I'm super excited about
because it's on them it's close to the
frontline of the conflicts but the city
itself I know has a different story to
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I made it here in Mary Opel Mary Opel
Ukraine I've never seen anything like
this in my life really far from what
seems to be everything else airport's
gonna close since 2014 so there's
there's really no easy way to get here
it's not this this like frontier feel to
it I was told 20 kilometers from the
separatist territory the russian-backed
separatists so that the conflict line is
not far from the city and then it's got
these factories
[Music]
these factories just like loom over the
city immediately I felt the place I felt
the air so I started feeling my nose a
little bit my eyes stung a little bit
they could definitely smell it and the
breathing was a bit heavier
welcome to Medi opal so the big factory
here I believe is as of Stahl there are
a couple of them it's interesting I hear
a lot of coughs like people on the on
the bus on the street and the coughs it
was like they're coughing like it was
flu season like in the fall late fall or
winter and it's now almost summer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
down here on the shores of the Sea of
Azov and it is it's unbelievable
actually it's unbelievable all this
slack it's like a mountain of slack
reaching into the water and then people
swimming in it and the stink is
horrendous down here oh my god if I was
a kid all I'd want to do is jump in this
water as the kids are doing and it's
definitely not good for anybody's help
I mean to this one neighborhood
everything's black like there's a black
silt on absolutely everything so we have
Palace for the workers you can see the
ecology level of here because you see
the stairs yeah black and the thing is
that people clean them every day
seriously every day come on every day
come on this buildings huh look at this
red behind it like this sort of haze
behind us so it's like this every day
here day and night yes it's pretty much
every day and sometimes they have the
waste thrown in the air and it's
literally orange color like a daylight
but with orange colouring the night and
the people here like this little girl on
the bike it's just all normal right yep
they used to she's actually I've been
here last year and I saw the kids
playing around just running and I have a
feeling like imagination that I'm in 30s
and talent still
the country by his still hand still fist
and it was pretty funny and I seen these
kids just playing and don't even care
about their planing they don't know yeah
you know it's all normal to them look at
that building okay it was right down in
2006 by white paint and this one do me
think
what are you supposed to think about
here if you'd think you'd be like
overthrowing the government yeah where's
you wait
well okay you did that I got it but say
the whoever allows this [ __ ] to happen
look at that place
think to choose your future that's
I can feel my throat it's normal it's
sure don't plan to get you feel it every
day
Bassel told me that he actually feels
sick when he gets into clean air we went
said these bison to our friends alone
leaves him
in the countryside and vice' had very
strong headache because the difference
of the air
so clean there that she had this you
know like noise noise noise you know I
said yeah so his father's head hurt when
he got away from the dirty oh yeah an
industrialized country needs metal but
it is 2019 there has to be a better way
than what's currently how it's currently
operating in the city because people are
just kidding living in toxins you can
see some some some kids five four years
old and they are really really sick with
yellow faces with the yellow eyes and
you understand the main reason office of
the ship and it make you really really
upset and really really depressed
because you don't know how you can help
them the main purpose of all of us for
all people it doesn't matter
here in Ukraine and you say wherever you
are is a house for yeah yeah yeah very
basic scene but all all this all these
guys all of these factories they say
they took past
else right they take your help yes they
took and they they keep on doing all
this things and yeah you can't change
this infrastructure overnight for sure
there has to be some sort of filtration
system that could be improved upon
because it's it's disgusted it's like
downright gross look if you if you dirty
the water you can always that sucks but
you can buy bottled water but if you if
you dirty the air you're just everyone's
a victim to it there's no choice in the
matter you can't buy bottled air and
then there were these guys fishing like
fishing right into this water right
where the the toxic water from the
factory was coming out people are
fishing
[Music]
[Applause]
some beautiful architecture here some
really nice architecture and then you
have this one building that's you know
in the conflict
it was obviously destroyed as you can
see bullet holes in there and it's burnt
out people who wanted to create the
Nazca people Republic came here and
started to shoot we had some fighters it
literally block away is this new park I
don't know if it's a new park but it's
redone it's absolutely beautiful
the juxtapositions here are insane like
the the mix like the contrast
[Music]
the main battle was there was right
there oh [ __ ] they had a couple of
bosses here at barricades and BTR went
over this barricades and here was the
guys with the rifles everybody was
shooting so the separatists had
controlled this building yeah and on the
other side was the free cranium meeting
and the guys just went over there had
some fight get back and now they built a
nice party are they gonna rebuild this
yeah you know five years ago you can see
that people are walking around where the
Russian Flags here in 2014 from a
geopolitical perspective this place is
super important and I believe everyone
knows that like it has to stay Ukrainian
if this fell if this city fell that
would that would be a huge blow the city
is the front line for a people's mind
people want to look on the west here and
I can see that people changing their
mentality more to the western side than
to the east so this city is very
important for this battle for the minds
it's a soft power battle - and I've seen
I've seen this in other parts of the
world I saw in Syria before the war
there when big powers are trying to win
over a population they set up things and
they invest in the infrastructure and
they try to win minds basically it's
what's going on and it's a tactic and
it's usually quite effective but you can
see it here you can see USAID all over
the place you can see other European
donors putting money into the effort
infrastructure it's not because only
they just want to be nice and how about
no it's creating influence
[Music]
you have these extremes you have this
these factories that are looming over
the city and making all the air dirty
but then you have like this crazy
opposite force here and you have the
young people and the young people are
the life of this city I thought the
young people had a lot of optimism but
they all uniformly said they hate the
ecology but they all uniformly said most
of them not she some wanted to move out
but most were like yeah I want to build
my city
yeah it's getting better the young
people start to see that they have a
possibilities they can not to leave this
city that it can live here and develop
here something and it became more
interesting for them because earlier
people just left the city because they
never installed the future in this place
and as I looked out into these
smokestacks I didn't really get him at
first but I saw like over some time I
saw went to this one coffee shop in this
this woman Lisa her family owner opened
wanna compete a thousand one and just
adored one reveal that opens do you love
your city yeah early
- baleen - Keith I didn't I just want to
live here but then I certainty I decided
- it's better to live here to work in my
place with my parents in about travel I
had amazing food here I had I love ramen
and I need some of the best for ramen
I've never had my life and so you have
this this crazy like insane mix here you
had this artistic community different
museums and different outlets for
artists you have this Watchtower in the
center of the city
[Music]
there's this co-working space I walked
into this co-working space it was
beautiful it was a brand new again
something you see out of like a very
modern dynamic city I was told by
everyone it's safe right now actually is
much more safer than any other city like
Kibo Karthik because a lot of military
here a lot of Iraq a lot of special
services here after many people moved
from here as a Libra as a city and I
wanted to leave the city to I you don't
really appreciate that peaceful
environment that you have right but then
after some tough times you start to
appreciate it you understand this piece
is very important in otherwise you can
develop yourself when it's peaceful
around do you feel it's more peaceful
now I thought that I felt like even
though it's gone through some seriously
tough times and it's got a very rough
edge to it actually felt quite peaceful
and you get on some of these streets in
there beautiful like tree-lined streets
families baby carriages just a really
cool mellow vibe and for a moment you
forget about the air and in these
factories look nobody has control over
these big forces that operate these
factories and these factories bring jobs
and I get a lot of the city I don't know
a percentage
I heard all different variations I heard
from 10% to like 40 percent are employed
by these these factors they bring jobs
and so many people need and want these
companies to be here obviously so yeah
this way it has two sides like
yeah people can't sleep without plans
because everything actually was built
because of these plans like the plan
came first and then the city can sort of
something like that yeah and some people
came to our sea to just work here and to
get paid it's more about older people or
not so young people because right they
just got used to live in those
conditions uh-huh they don't want to
change something because they're afraid
of changes some inspirational stuff on
the street yeah that's me 16 hour ago
what would you write on the board if you
could write something on the board what
we do
this is probably what it was like when
the Industrial Revolution was going on
like these conditions this air quality
it comes down to bottom line and people
making money and that's all that matters
and the human toll on the human cost is
not a consideration for the people that
run these operations my grandfather
always been working on the factories
he's 72 now but almost all his friends
except one died already because of
cancer because of this toxic [ __ ] we
have a mentality in our people we will
go to the hospital when it's too late
we're living in [ __ ] but I will be much
happier if this if here will be much
less of this [ __ ] and I will take my
hand to create something to make it
better I will feel better personally so
leaving the very nice restaurant going
up to the streets
and boom there it is that smell that
medi opal smell can you see it what the
haziness no but use you also drink a
liter of coca-cola every day and swim in
the water so you don't feel anything
well I you're a mutant alright Borowski
it's been fun
thank you
[Music]
this city is one of the most interesting
bizarre mixed-up extreme beautiful
depressing places I've ever been in my
life a lot of forces that play
despite the air the air kills me but
despite that like there's something
really likable about this city and I'm
really glad I can at the end of the day
it's it's always the people and the
people stepped up helped out so
authentic so kind so genuine
[Music]
[Music]
that's my story
[Music]
[Applause]